org
okay ready to begin good evening
I'm Bradley Graham and the co-owner of
politics and prose along with my wife
Lissa Muscatine and on behalf of the
entire staff thank you for for coming
a few quick administrative notes that
would be a good time to turn off your
cellphone's or anything that might go
beep when we get to the Q&A part of the
session if you have a question please
make your way to this microphone here
because as you can see we are we are
filming both for our YouTube channel and
also first c-span book TV so we like to
be able to hear your question and also
if you use the microphone others in the
store can can hear the question as well
and at the end before you come up to get
your book sign our staff would
appreciate it if you'd fold up the
chairs that you're sitting in and lean
them against something that looks like
it won't won't topple over this evening
or we're going to to hear about a pretty
remarkable true story a one that that
hasn't really been told before the story
of what author and journalist Julian
Boyer calls the world's most successful
manhunt this manhunt targeted 161
individuals wanted for war crimes in
connection with the Balkan conflicts of
the 1990s remember that was the period
when when the term ethnic cleansing
emerged as a kind of euphemism for the
wholesale slaughter that was once again
taking place in the heart of Europe
those responsible for this brutality
were identified and indicted
subsequently by the International
Criminal Tribunal for more Yugoslavia a
special court in The Hague created in
1993 by the United Nations it was the
first time that a global court had been
established to pursue war criminals and
it ended up engaging in an even more
substantial hunt than the search for
Nazis after World War
by 2011 all 161 of those indicted had
either been captured or killed or had
surrendered or committed suicide now a
lot of the manhunt was conducted in
secret and involved special forces from
a number of countries spy agencies and
even an intrepid tracking unit inside
the hague tribunal itself but their
achievement and and the subsequent
trials have set a precedent for how
international authorities can bring
justice to bear against those
responsible for mass atrocities and
other crimes against humanity through
much dogged reporting a Julien who's an
experienced British journalist has
pieced together this amazing story he's
drawn on more than 200 interviews with
soldiers intelligence officials
investigators diplomats and others and
he also attained access to files of
previously secret British government
documents julian covered the Bosnian war
for the BBC and then the Guardian living
in Sarajevo in the mid-1990s and in 1999
he returned to the Balkans to report on
the Kosovo conflict he's currently a
world affairs editor of The Guardian and
was part of the team that won the
Guardians 2014 Pulitzer for public
service journalism for coverage of the
Edward Snowden files
Julian's book the butcher's the
butcher's trail has received very
favorable reviews for both its abundant
detail and gripping narrative style Kirk
has called the book quote a vivid page
turning account and the New York Journal
of Books said quote this fascinating
tale is difficult to put down and reads
like the best written of true crime so
please join me in warrant warmly
welcoming Julian border
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you very much
to politic some pros for having me here
and I really loved that in the the
publicity they referred me as
distinguished which is a word is not
used in connection with me since my mum
and I went prematurely gray my early
thirties it is thank you very much to
all the friends who've come out here
tonight and if they were here my
publishers other press who took a
suddenly tough leap of faith in
publishing this book and it I realised
just how big a leap they'd had they
taken when they came back to me after
reading and saying why are there so many
names ending a niche but although I was
pleased to see at least initially and
the Amazon rankings so ty was our first
bestseller and a European politics but
the edge was slightly taken after that
of fact when I saw the number two was
mr. a Hitler and the realists of his
mind camp but you know what what the
publisher said you know there are too
many names ending in each it really is
you know says so much about the problem
of the West and Western intervention in
Bosnia and the Balkans and you know
perhaps it's because so many names ended
it a niche and it all seems so very
complicated that it took three years to
intervener
and stop that war and to stop the
killing and and it was my hope with this
book to kind of break through that
barrier and and focus on what is
Universal from this story which is the
issue of mass atrocities the issue of
international humanitarian law and the
enforcement of that law which is one of
the the hardest and toughest problems in
foreign policy then and now as badly
Bradley said I was it I was in Bosnia
during the war
and and afterwards and my colleagues who
are there and I were astonished after
the war when there were 64,000 NATO
troops in Bosnia and they didn't go up
after these people who'd been indicted
for some of you know the worst crime
since the Nazi era and they they
actually made a point of avoiding going
after them and in fact they are only
that policy had only changed just after
I left it the region in 97 but I kept
tabs on it and saw that it the arrests
gathered momentum and finally they got
down to the big fish
Radovan Karadzic they got in 2008 Ratko
Mladic
in 2011 and then finally they got the
last guy go-around hajjaj and i wrote up
a magazine piece of at the time because
I thought it was striking that here was
a UN mission that had actually been
completed they had 161 names on their
lists and they actually went through it
they took a long time and they finally
completed it and and in doing quite a
short magazine story it occurred to me
Wally became a evident to me that there
was a much bigger story underneath that
had to be they hadn't been told one of a
vast and sprawling manhunt if you talk
to intelligence and Special Forces
people who were in the business in the
late 90s up to 9/11 of more than likely
they would have been involved in that
manhunt one way or another it was the
biggest deployment of Special Forces
troops anywhere before 9/11 but it
became it was buried under layers of
secrecy because it would involve the
intelligence and Special Forces but also
it came to an interrupted
midway through by 9/11 and then all
attention was focused on the war on
terror
which this manhunt directly segwayed
into the people who were looking for the
war criminals in Bosnia went off
immediately and went to Afghanistan went
to Iraq the first renditions were from
Sarajevo the people who've been involved
in the manhunt went into the hotel
Hollywood in Bude Mir and picked up a
Jordanian an Egyptian and they as far as
I know a few days after 9/11 were the
first people to undergo suffer
renditions to their respective countries
and I find it very hard to find out what
had happened to them since and but I did
find it the man had an extraordinary
story and from the very beginning the
first operation arrest operation
specifically for The Hague war tribe's
war crimes tribunal was called Operation
little flower which was a sort of pick
up team a mixed multinational team under
the UN flag which is a way was dead
showed everything all the best that the
UN can be it was a group of people
brought together who's serving a common
mandate it was a diplomat general an
American different I general called Jack
Lang lives in this town a American
prosecutor Ken Williamson a British
Bobby from Stratford and Haven a Czech
homicide detective and a Polish special
forces unit and they concocted this
elaborate sting operation to lure one of
the war criminals over the border so
that they could be arrested and they did
so pretty much without the knowledge or
the approval of their of their own
governments and this act of slightly
maverick act opened the floodgates
because until then NATO who was in over
in Bosnia didn't want to get involved
they called it mission creep to go after
the war criminals they were there they
said to keep the peace
they don't want to do anything else
after that it became much harder to make
the argument that is far too dangerous
for our troops because this was a bunch
of a bunch of UN officials and some
untrain untried unknown polish soldiers
so they set up a a joint operation
called amber star in Stuttgart the US UK
France Germany Netherlands and the
original idea was to have a
multinational big multinational sweep
and pick up everyone pretty much at the
same time involving going in to parlay
which was the Bosnian Serb headquarters
with guns blazing and it was never clear
to me whether they actually meant to do
this or they created a operation that
would be so scare the politicians that
they would cancel it but it was never
put to the test because the whole thing
was torpedoed by a an espionage and sex
scandal that came to be known as the
gore Milan affair after hell they're
gone Monell was a major French major
whose job it was to go up and down the
road from Sarajevo to paly
see the Bosnian Serbs and the CIA became
convinced that the flow of information
was going the wrong way and that he was
giving away far more information that he
was collecting from the Carrey's circle
so the CI complained about him where's
Clarke complained about him he was
recalled to Paris and debriefed but the
the French hierarchy send it back and
kind of gave a kind of Gallic shrug and
it and it occurred I think to the US
intelligence officers on the ground that
maybe this wasn't an individual act that
it was a very French form of force
protection and that they would let the
SERPs know we'll be going in and having
a sweeper we'll be looking for some of
your guys so if you don't want any
trouble you might want to stay out of
that air
the the end result was the same
but gorman lot ended up leaving
sorry Havel eventually because one night
a a young woman came into a police
station in Sarajevo complained that
she'd been sexually assaulted quite
violently by him and this was presented
to the French generals on the spot and
he was out within hours leaving his
property his clothes and possessions
behind him whether he was set up or
whether this was you know something he
did remains unclear but the the end
result was he was out and that
franco-american military and
intelligence relations were were very
much soured for the following years and
after that Amber star didn't really
count for anything everyone went their
own way everyone did things in their own
zones and the British started off and
they did a a better dozen arrests in
their zone bringing with them their kind
of rough-edged
techniques that they had perfected in
Northern Ireland and then the the Dutch
who were operating and the wealth weight
of guilt of having been the soldiers who
were supposed to have protected
Schreiber Aneesa then you had the u.s.
who learned man hunting techniques there
that they would take on into the war and
on terror and you had the Germans who
went into action for the first time in
this man hand for the first time since
the Second World War and took their
first casualty since the Second World
War
in this manhunt and then finally the
French the most reluctant participants
whose first time out turned out to be a
real disaster they killed the guy and
almost killed a bunch of kids who were
travelling with him but then went on to
capture one of the biggest prizes of all
and so by the time of 9/11 when everyone
was shipped out to Afghanistan and
entered to Iraq a lot of the small fry
had been hoovered up but what that meant
is the big fish the people who would
give a
the orders had got away they've been by
seeing the others being at the small fry
being picked up they fled to Serbia and
Croatia where they found safe haven and
the second the next stage in the manhunt
was about putting the pressure on those
governments in in Belgrade and in Zagreb
to do the hunting themselves in immense
economic pressure and ultimately the big
fish were only arrested when there was a
fundamental political change in those
countries and and then in those
countries their intelligence agencies
and what I'll do is I'll read an excerpt
about the final when Karadzic Radovan
Karadzic was finally arrested in 2008
after those political changes has
happened so by 2008 Radovan Karadzic was
Europe's most wanted man and his
greatest embarrassment the self-declared
Republic the former psychiatrist and
poet had carved out of Bosnia had bought
death camps mass executions and genocide
back to the heart of a continent that
had fooled itself into thinking it had
left such abominations behind the
atrocities in Bosnia had drawn
expressions of horror and outrage from
the capitals of Europe yet it had taken
three years to stop the killing and
twelve more years as zip-tie in which
the West combined intelligence agencies
supposedly stretched every sinew to find
the perpetrators yet Karadzic the
wartime president of Bosnian Serb atop a
republic and high priests of ethnic
cleansing remained at large at large and
every day he was at Liberty called into
question the world's promises to sit in
judgment on the killings that had failed
to stop the pursuit of Karadzic had been
marked by false starts blunders
betrayals and near misses from the
abortive negotiations over surrender the
spy drama of the
my affair and the consequent
long-running franco-american spat
followed by a series of would-be
American ambushes that the fugitive
always managed to avoid either by Blind
Luck
tip-offs or a highly sensitive nose for
danger and this was a frustrating state
of affairs in early 2008 when out of the
blue
luck for once abandoned the fugitive in
favor of his pursuers one of the many
dormant phone numbers on the BIA that
see a Serb intelligence agency list
suddenly rang after four years of
silence more interesting still the
person using the SIM card in question
was Luca heritage Radovan younger
brother and staunchest defender Luca was
a blustering small-time businessman
preoccupied with defending himself
against charges of killing a young woman
in a drunk driving incident in 2005 but
who was Luca calling the voice on the
other end of the phone was unfamiliar to
the BIA eavesdroppers it was male
but high-pitched with a Belgrade accent
but the stilted briefing tree
conversation told them nothing more a
couple of investigators were sent to
take a look at the address to which the
mystery man's phone number was
registered they returned having
discovered his name was Dragan David
Dabish a somewhat eccentric old
character who lived in one of the
high-rise apartment blocks that lined
yuri gagarin street named in honor of
the first man of space in the shabby
remains of the concrete socialist dream
that was new belgrade above a bushy
white beard and glasses he sported a top
knot tied with a black bow perched
distractingly on his snowy hair Babbage
made a living as a New Age mystic
offering spiritual cures for chronic
diseases and every day manna dey's in
the world of alternative medicine he was
a minor celebrity
with a regular column in the national
magazine healthy living a part-time gig
representing a connecticut based on
vitamin con company calivita and a joint
project with a well known sexologist
aimed at rejuvenating the sperm of
infertile men the therapist in question
claimed that the sly
sperm would start moving faster if
Dabish placed his hands in their
facility damage seemed an unlikely
acquaintance for the hard-drinking
splenetic Lukic heritage who had
hitherto shown little interest in
alternative alternative lifestyles
so the BIA officers dug a little deeper
and the more they looked into the life
of this white-haired Shaymin the
stranger he appeared according to his
identity records Babbage came from a
town called rumah west of Belgrade
halfway to the Croatian border but there
was one rather glaring discrepancy there
was another dragon damage and rumor was
exactly the same date of birth and this
version looked nothing like the looming
Gandalf figure in new Belgrade he was a
squat former construction worker with
short gray hair and a drooping moustache
who grew tomatoes and made plump brandy
he barely strayed more than five miles
from his birthplace in his entire life
and didn't even own a mobile phone the
records show only one dragon Dabish had
been born in Roma in the 1940s so one of
these two men was clearly an impostor
and it didn't take Sherlock Holmes to
deduce which there were other aspects of
damage which didn't fit the lifestyle of
a spiritual healer he carried half a
dozen mobile phones used some of them to
make contact with hardline Serb
nationalists campaigning against the
hague tribunal a bi officer was sent
back to 267 gagarin street to hang
around and take a closer look strolling
past him in the road the officer turned
returned with the startling suggestion
perhaps this hairy spiritualist was not
the mysterious link to Radovan Karadzic
the surveillance team had suspected if
you cut off the top knot you shaved the
beard and removed the glasses Babbage
could be carriage' to himself by this
time word had reached perigee she was
being watched according to his lawyer
sweater voyage the fugitive began to
spot unfamiliar faces in mid-july
rushing past him on the stairwell at his
apartment block or his favorite by the
the culture the madhouse he knew he was
encircled footage said the endgame had
begun in which the fugitive King was
running out of pawns to shield himself
from his hunters but he wasn't prepared
to simply wait for them to come knocking
on his door on July the 17th the BIA
surveillance team sounded the alarm
after seeing two identified men entered
the damaged apartment with large bags it
looked like the old man was getting
ready to run the next evening Dabish
left
Gagarin Street in a not light blue
t-shirt and a broad-brimmed straw hat
that was pulled low over his face he was
weighed down with baggage a white
plastic bag a raffia a shopping basket
and a knapsack all of which seemed to be
full he walked to a nearby bus stop
where he was soon discreetly joined by
one of his BIA trackers they boarded the
number 73 bus bound for the suburb of a
Bethany sir about eight miles to the
south northwest Babbage sat near the
front his shadow sat several seats back
as the bus lumbered through the streets
from the concrete towers of new Belgrade
into the older richer and leafy ADIZ
district of Zemin this eccentric
conflicted character known as dragon
damaged now in his last minutes of a
long-running performance but on his
clear glass spectacles and opened a
spirituals text through the window city
blocks gave way to green fields turning
gold in the light of a Balkan summer
evening the unhurried calm inside the
bus contrasted with the hectic activity
in the surrounding streets triggered by
damage a sudden departure from new
Belgrade Sasha VUCA de vich the new BIA
chief had set up at a snatch plan in
motion said a snatched pan in motion a
few stops before but any sir in the
green belt around Belgrade a couple of
patrol cars steered in front of the bus
and four plainclothes policemen got out
two in the front two ogre got on two in
the front and two in the back they made
their way towards damage his seat posing
as inspectors showing their badges and
asking to see two stickers
the old man in the straw hat was
reaching into his pocket for his fare
when he felt a policeman's grip around
his arm doctor Karadzic the policeman
asked no it's a truck and a [ __ ]
the man protested no is Radovan Karadzic
the policeman insisted are your
superiors aware of what you're doing the
man asked yes Foley in the reply the
officer ordered the driver to stop the
bus and the captive was exported onto
the grass shoulder at 9:30 p.m. on July
the 18th 2008 the flamboyant flit
fiction that had been Dragon David
Dabish evaporated in his place the ghost
of Radovan Karadzic who had haunted the
balkans for a decade REE materialized on
a Belgrade roadside as a flustered old
man his straw hat askew clutching a
white plastic bag to his breast few
three years later they finally got Ratko
Mladic would become isolated by this
time in one of his cousin's farmhouses
and he although the most ruthless of men
was was given away by a moment of
sentimentality they were following his
bia were following his son who went to a
on a feast day to that village because
he had several cousins there and during
this visit two of the Czech
grandchildren walked into the courtyard
of a cousin's house which was as far as
I knew empty because all the cousins
were elsewhere partying and the
grandchildren stood in this courtyard
for several minutes and then left and
they all went to the family party and
they could figure out why had they done
it and they raided the place and
upstairs in a small room pretty much in
his under pepper underwear they found
recomm knowledge and the reason he was
caught was he wanted to see his children
he wouldn't be able to tour his
grandchildren he wouldn't
have to talk to them but he wanted to
see them in the courtyard and then a few
months later the last man
Goren Hodge was caught in the woods in
northern Serbia bringing to an end
17-year manhunt the lessons from the
manhunt were in one way technical one of
the Special Forces guys from Delta Force
involved said everything we did in Iraq
and Afghanistan when it came to man
hunting we learnt in Bosnia they learnt
that is better to go small than big
they learned how to use drones they
learned how to integrate intelligence
and Special Forces but the bigger lesson
the lesson from from my point of view it
was taken away from this experience was
the realization that peace is never
enduring without justice the generals
who went into Bosnia and who resisted
any talk of mission creep learned after
about a year that it wasn't working but
by leaving the war criminals at large
was undermining the Dayton peace process
the whole idea of returning people
returning people to their homes and
reintegrating the country was being
sabotaged by these people
so after painfully over many months they
learned this lesson that an enduring
peace had to be accompanied by some
measure of justice but in a way at my
impression is that those lessons have
been unlearned since this manhunt and
this rather forgotten manhunt and the
strength of the ICC the International
Criminal Court which is in a way the the
there's a legacy of The Hague Tribunal
has been it has been undermined to the
point where you can only really function
in Africa which is a problem in itself
international humanitarian law and its
enforcement out of fashion but I mean I
think the present situation in the
Middle East is a demonstration that if
you think that the enforcement of
international humanitarian law is
expensive you should try impunity
because in a way the situation in in
Syria the growth of - Isis are
outcroppings of the commission of mass
atrocities by murderous regimes that
have gone forward with impunity and this
book had has any policy purpose is to
demonstrate that there is an alternative
to that route and that the enforcement
of intact international humanitarian law
is not simply pie in the sky idealistic
that it has been done and it has worked
thanks much anyone want to ask a
question thank you thank you for coming
looking at the situation now 20 years
out from the Dayton Peace Accords more
than 20 years now
what do you think of the situation in
general in the Balkans and in general in
Europe with the refugee crisis the
increasing start from terrorism do you
think there is a possibility that it
could happen again and this time spread
I kind of wide um thank you
you're right I'm 20 years after Dayton
and you go back to Bosnia and it is a
depressing sight the peace agreement
that that ended the war has also
constrained and strangled the peace by
dividing
Bosnia on earth NIC lines and making it
really difficult to succeed politically
if you don't fly the ethnic flag and
that has deepened the division made it
really hard for it to function as a
state that has contribute to paralysis
has got a highest youth unemployment
rate anywhere in the world by official
physique figures and no I don't think it
will lead to war like we saw it in the
90s because they've had enough and
because I think you know the Europe can
not allow at this time and they've seen
this movie before and I don't think
they're going to let it play out
again but you that doesn't mean that
everything is fine this is a festering
sore it is remarkable to me there isn't
more there are more jihadists coming out
of buzzing because it's a miserable
place and many of the bosniak that
Muslims situate citizens have to live in
a situation where what happened to them
has been denied by their neighbors
they're not allowed to talk about it the
people who went back to Japanese were
not allowed to talk about what happened
if they want to get along so it amazes
me there aren't there is no more no
bigger JavaScript threat Isis is trying
very hard to have very high end
production videos aimed at the region
trying to recruit people and I don't
think Europe is going to get away with
it for much longer
it may not be war like we saw it in
nineteen in a mid-90s but it won't be
pretty
I teach the law of war at Georgetown but
it's unclear to me why the United States
is so anti ICC which I the ICC having
great promise it seems to me even now do
you have any insight as to why the
United States has taken such an
intransigent position for the success of
the ICC I mean it seems to me as a
professor George can just and you
probably know didn't better than me but
Clinton signed it in the last his last
days in office to fulfill a promise
whether he meant it ever to go through
expected ever to go through it it's hard
to say but as you know the Bush
administration one of the first things I
did was not simply just kind of squelch
the ratification process they went as
far as to unsign it and it is about I
think the idea of exceptionalism that
there must ever and must never ever come
a time when an American would face for
injustice even though that the the Rome
Statute that set up the ICC is full of
safeguards that if you have a
functioning law system of kind of any
kind you won't face justice ICC but but
the the mood mood in in the Bush
administration is you know why should we
take the risk we are the world's most
powerful country and then the price of
exceptionalism means you're not creating
a you're not creating international
norms you're not creating a rule of law
and you pay a long-term price but as you
know well the pro the prospects of
ratification of their own statute or for
any major international treaty are
pretty grim with the Congress we have
here right now
I was wondering about your thoughts on
why it took so long to get this whole
process running uh we were there we saw
eurorack Oh Mudge was skiing up in Pali
these guys were running around and it
seemed that maybe there was method to
the madness they wanted things to settle
down and they didn't want to go after
them immediately so why did the whole
process take so long to get started I
that's a very good question and I think
it's really hard now to go back to that
mindset the military mindset before 9/11
and after so much blood has been spilt
on largely pointless conflicts to
remember how risk-averse the military
was back then in the 90s it was said
that if you were a a general in the US
Armed Forces
in that time your chances of getting an
extra star were minimal if you had
casualties under your watch
it was the most career destroying thing
that could happen and so for that reason
as you remember up in Tuzla the US
forces who came in as part of the
international peacekeeping peacekeeping
force they played baseball in their flak
jackets and helmets you know and not a
shot had been fired after the after the
Dayton treated pretty much the but it
wasn't just the u.s. it was the the
Brits and the French none of them wanted
to risk casualties for a task that
wasn't specifically mandated in the
Dayton peace agreement and as far as
they were concerned they were there to
keep the peace not to do these other
things and it took about a year year and
after for the penny to drop that
actually the peace depended on removing
these people thank you very much for so
for your presentation very interesting
my question is you
historian when looking at this mass
crimes mass genocide I look at the roles
of perpetrators victims and only more
recently about the role of beast Anders
so my question is how did people
responded to this mass hunting what was
the response of people a Serbian crud or
Bosnian to this massive mass hunting of
these war criminals in former Yugoslavia
it very much depended on who and in not
just a question of their nestea I mean
obviously obviously the most Bosniaks
were right behind it because they had
been 80% of the civilian casualties from
the war had been buzzing so the main
victims so they were very much in
support amongst Serbs and Christ Jaina
the the nationalists were very much
against it because they saw it as
seeding sovereignty we will take care of
our own issues thank you very much
having just gained independence they
didn't want to be seeding their own
sovereignty to some international court
plus they were complicit themselves and
what changed was the arrival in office
of people who saw the future in Europe
but also wanted to draw a line between
those people that were responsible for
the mass atrocities and the people as a
whole they didn't want that all of Serbs
or crimes to be seen as being complicit
in this they and so the way to get out
of that was to find the guilty man and
all but one were men in terms of the
pagan deities at least and to hand them
over but that was a question of
political evolution
all right thank you very much for coming
and I look forward to reading your book
thank you I'm bill Nash and I was the
American commander in Bosnia in 1995-96
and I and I just like to make a couple
of comments first of all we were not
smart enough to do what was done a year
later you're a year and a half later and
it took the whole institution a long
time to figure it all out
and as I told one of the visitors we got
one time asking me if I could go capture
blight because my niche was in my air in
the American sector cut garbage was in
the French sector I said sure I said I
know where Hans Pisac is I know where
his headquarters is but I don't do
snatches I got to take division now I
can destroy the goddamn mountain and I
can go in there and sort out who's left
and if he's there I'll anja his body or
his alive or dead but I don't do
statutes you got to do it better that's
one point the second point I would say
is is that having spoken to senior
American political leaders senior
national leaders from all of the country
of all the countries participating there
was not a political directive to the
military to perform it and the only
thing I really take exception with what
you had to say tonight was the fact that
it's not up to the generals what they do
it's up to the government to tell the
generals what to do mm-hm
and and we would all sacrifice our
democracy in the civilian control of the
military if you were to put yourself in
a position whether it be Bosnia or Iraq
or Afghanistan where the generals were
making political decisions yeah and so I
I don't I don't excuse us for not being
smarter but I do think it was a good
idea to listen to the president
United States I mean it would say would
one thing I absolutely agreed that
certainly before the clinton's
reelection in in ninety six that there
was absolutely no willpower at all they
would must be no nothing that will upset
the reelection campaign i mean my
understanding is after that they had a
previous principals meeting when they
made this Clinton and gore said this is
something we ought to do and and and
very much to Cohen's dismay the defense
agree at the time and but between that
time and when of the American arrests
Elisa's began there was there was a lot
of internal institutional resistance
because of this issue of you're telling
us to do this but if we have casualties
them you know if we if we suffer
casualties we will be be the one to want
to blame and I got the impression you
could correct me if I'm wrong that it
was an inter age you know that Albright
and where's Clark were very much for it
but then you had someone like Eric
Shinseki on the ground whose troops he
believed would would bear the backlash
if there were if someone was killed or
if there was a backlash for their arrest
who are pushing my very much against
right yes thanks thank you for the book
thank you for your outstanding reporting
that preceded the book from from the
Balkans as well I would say there was an
informed view among some policy people
Expo X government people human rights
activists in this town and and some in
Europe that the principal actors were
were given in some form immunity by in
in the course of the Dayton negotiations
and that certainly some of those
figures believed that they had received
it what what if anything did you uncover
on that front well I mean Karadzic and
and the people around cottage garage
Dickinson have made two distinct claims
about immunity one the Richard Holbrooke
probably promising and second one of the
the Chirac had promised them and they
you here in intercepts when they're
talking to each other so they said well
sure I can't promise us and so you know
how can this this this happen
and with Holbrooke I doubt it I can
imagine a situation in you know who's a
very able negotiator I can imagine a
situation in which he intimated that
maybe we'll be less of a problem if they
just signed here but Henan was never
stupid enough to commit himself in any
way it's certainly not in writing and
they've never been able to produce
something around with the French is
different they at the the end of the war
they had two pilots who were shot down
captured and there was long drawn-out
negotiations and money changed hands
that seems to be clear some arms weapons
are likely to change hands and it is
quite possible that some soft promises
were made that don't worry about the
tribunal and certainly not to me but
French officials told told a French
journalist who wrote a book about about
this like my say that they understood of
that under the Scirocco administration
undertakings were given were were given
but they were probably given knowing
that they're empty because it wasn't in
the gift of the fridge not ultimately
very much it seems like the general mood
in the Balkans now is that the ICTY has
been largely a disappointment for a
variety of reasons do you think the
courts ultimately been successful
compared to them and not do you think
it's lived up to the effort that was put
into it
I mean when I call this you know they're
in the strip line the most successful
man hunted really referred to the man
and getting the bodies into the court
and not the decisions the court then
made which are controversial there been
some very controversial
acquittals although the most
controversial ones have been now
reversed
they haven't covered themselves in glory
and at the end it's going to be a hot
you know glass half-full sort of story
if you talk to the families of the dead
in Bosnia they will say it took so long
so few people have been tried to face
justice some of them are already out
because you know some of the worst
criminals have faced the world's most
lenient penal system and so they will
say it's very much half full but the the
idea of it not happening at all is
unthinkable and if some measure of
justice was done it will never be enough
for the kind of scale of killing that
took place and it could have been it's a
bit like the UN you know it's completely
flawed it falls over itself as it odds
with itself but you know if you
abolished it you'd have to reinvent it
the next day yep that's right you view
like a similar manhunt and it's up one
day for a Syrian of war criminals I
really really hope so I know that some
of the people who were involved in this
manhunt and now building prosecution
cases so that one day they'll be able
maybe to prosecute people in the Assad
regime people in - and what they're
doing very bravely is smuggling out the
documents that could one day prove these
people are guilty smuggling them out of
Syria and keeping them in Europe and and
going through them and building a case
that the one day convict these people
but first you need
a tribunal at court and for that you
need the world to agree where you need
to the Security Council to agree so we
if one day there's a court there's at
least a case there the could put them in
jail so so by my necessity these
operations when they were occurring were
were secretive how hard was it for you
to ferret out what happened how willing
were many of the participants know how
to talk years later I think what I took
out they the experience was to get used
to rejection I would say you know 3/4
5/6 told me to go to hell which was
quite right there you know for
intelligence Special Forces but you know
that quarter that six are people who
think wow you know it's a story worth
telling it was an amazing story we did
the right thing it's good that it comes
out so ultimately you know the I had
moments when I thought I'm not going to
be able to do this so you know people
are just not going to talk about it in
the end you know there's a percentage of
people who who take that view and new
way to talk anymore questions
so cut copies of Julian's book are
available at the cash register
please remember to fold up your chairs
and he'll be at the table up here
signing books so please form a line to
the right